other times you know it is very it can  be very very cosmic it can be steered  and this is a very phenomenon that  totally puzzles me that many people have  verified which is you can give it a  theme like you can say art deco and this  stuff will begin flowing toward you  millions and millions and millions of  cigarette lighters ashtrays glasses  dresses all this stuff all perfectly  realized Art Deco high art deco and then  you can just say you know no Hellenic  Greece and it just and it does that and  then you can say okay do one I've never  seen and you can do that and you say  okay now make it weird  I just okay that's weird enough